rich Lerner the golf channel back here
in the Rich Eisen show what you think
rich well it's a new generation good to
be already rich
they certainly respect Tiger they they
know what he's done for the game what
he's done for them put money in their
pocket with his huge TV contracts but
they no longer fear tiger maybe someday
that'll change but that was a sneaking
great performance by Molinari 69 it's
not sort of a mind-blowing number like a
64 in the final round but given how
difficult Carnoustie played 2-under PAR
without a bogey under the pressure
playing alongside you know a mythical
creature as Shaun Norris on Saturday
Tigers playing partner Shawn Norris
called him a mythical creature without a
bogey for two days this a case of a guy
who was sort of a journeyman for a long
time in his mid-30s in the last two
months suddenly figuring something out
and he's been a great player the best
player in the world the last two months
he keeps it up we don't know but I saw
this I was on the call for the BMW PGA
Championship it's the flagship event on
the European Tour played outside of
London in May and Molinari thoroughly
outplayed Rory McIlroy for two days over
the weekend I mean kicked his rear end
up down sideways didn't miss a shot but
the thing is we'd always called them
kind of a ball striking genius but
didn't make enough putts he's added sort
of creativity magic touch the last two
months and it's made him a different
player he's now the 6th ranked player in
the world and he's every bit of that
yeah I know and and again I didn't see
his round on Saturday very much but
obviously I was locked in on Sunday I
don't even think he came in through the
side door with any of his putts rich I
mean it and it's hot too I mean this is
a guy in his mid-30s who was just always
known as kind of a boring ball striker
if you ever listen to our telecast on
Golf Channel
anytime Francesco Molinari came on the
screen with Francesco Molinari second
shot here at number seven one of the
game's premier ball striker strikers
struggles a bit on the greens
and so you know he just kind of
languished he was a good earner made
money 25th 28 33rd in the world that
kind of guy but never made me noise but
he is a different guys training
differently he's looking at data and I
think that's the beauty of golf rich is
that you can age well Ben Hogan didn't
really peak until he was in his mid to
late 30s Padraig Harrington won three
majors beginning at the age of 36
so it's possible Nick Foles won a Super
Bowl as you know sort of a journeyman
quarterback but it was a an incredible
day in a lot of ways the first sort of
four to five hours with Tiger peaking
and Tiger threatening were more exciting
than the last say 30 40 minutes but when
you had six guys at one point tied at
six under par and three or four the
biggest names would Spieth Justin Rose
Rory McIlroy with the eagle at 14 it was
off the chain and it turned out to be
the highest rated final round of an open
since Tiger won in 2006 in Liverpool Wow
rich Lerner of the golf channel here on
the Rich Eisen show and you know Johnny
Miller was commenting during the NBC
broadcast rich that Tiger was moving
spectacularly that that it that he
didn't have a care in the world
now whatever was going on with his back
whatever might have been going on with
his whatever was between his temples
which is amazing that that that that he
would have any sort of mental lapse
during a golf during a round at all so
based on what he what he did back in the
day
I mean he's back right rich we don't
even need to have that conversation I
mean he's all he's back in the
conversation there's no doubt about it
I mean he's right there but he's not
back to what he was but let's just turn
backtrack May of a year ago when he kind
of hit bottom right side of the road
middle of the night I was personally
concerned for his health forget about
his golf so I didn't really think this
was possible I had my doubts and even
Tiger late last year
wasn't sure if he was going to be
playing again I mean at the Presidents
Cup you know in September Tiger was
hitting 60 yard pitch shots that was the
most that he could do he started the
year outside the top 600 in the world
he's now up to number 50 so I think the
hunger and the ambition are all the way
back the intensity is back the swing
I think his back what's not quite there
is the ability to finish and that's
mental and that's odd to say about a guy
who was you know the all-time closer I
mean when he had the lead at 7-under old
Tiger slams the door shut there's no
chance for anyone else old Tiger but
that this is a different guy who went
through a tremendous you know emotional
trauma going all the way back to 2009 10
11 so you have to allow for Tiger to
sort of learn all over again how to
handle the heat again that sounds
bizarre he was the all-time no doubt
about it guy now there's some doubt but
I think it's it's fun to watch and and
we sort of know the day will will come
soon where we're writing that story is
this one of the greatest sports
comebacks
of all time and you know that's a
discussion for another day it it will be
debated and it you know yesterday we
were sort of preparing you know
comparables you know terms of the
enormity of that story a tiger win it in
a recent vintage I think it would have
been caught me if I'm out of line here
but probably would have been along the
lines of Cubs winning a World Series for
the first time in over a century
LeBron coming from 3-1 down to bring the
NBA title back to the land is that fair
no I know I hear you I think the LeBron
one is one but the Cubs I mean it's I
mean we've seen Tiger win I mean that
this would've been the comeback story I
think you've mentioned it before about
obviously Hogan you've about some of the
comebacks that we've seen it definitely
wouldn't up there with some of the
greatest comeback
yeah we've ever seen unless your bazaars
we're going there a lesser note but I'm
sure for this particular athlete it was
monumental andre agassi sure came back
from some dependency issues and some
injuries to win I think it was five
majors a Peyton Manning had correct me
if I'm wrong a broken neck and one Super
Bowl after that right yes Monica Seles
was was stabbed and two years later came
back to win a major so something in that
that that category Tigers you know an
athlete of such Fame I mean no doubt
really he moves the needle that's why I
think LeBron LeBron's a an excellent
example a couple more minutes left with
rich Lerner of the golf channel what
should that say I'm gonna phrase it what
should come the conversation be about
jordan Spieth rich good question I know
sometimes he's difficult to figure what
but um moms and grandmom's he's the boy
next door right he's really likable he's
authentic moms and grandmom's wherever I
go they say what's wrong with my Jordans
right there's my Jordan he's that kind
of guy but I think part of Jordan's
appeal is that he is so vulnerable and
and fidgety and jumpy and at times
unsure and you want to reach out and
pull him close but then he'll turn
around and and it'll do something that
blows your mind and we're constantly
referencing Jordan in in the context of
he he's about to join fill in the
blanket somebody who played golf in the
silent movie era Gene Sarazen in the
1920s or even someone who played in the
Reconstruction period in late eighteen
sixties young Tom Morris in other words
every time he's about to win a major
he's going to achieve something of
incredible historical significance
yesterday would have been four majors at
the age of 24 it's a very short list it
would have been back-to-back opens the
the the only other player to do that
before the age of 25 was young Tom
so he's done amazing things he has the
it factor he the last thing I'll say
about Jordan he's the great quarterback
he'll throw two interceptions and you'll
go oh you're killing me
all right and then the next game he'll
thread the needle with 10 seconds left
from 20 yards out you'll swear he's the
greatest thing you've ever seen he has
that it factor and and I I don't worry
long-term about Jordan he's he's a he's
a great athlete and a great great young
person a great chat as always rich will
chat with you before the PGA
Championship let's do it you got safe
travels they so richly honor Golf
Channel the rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience